i was uh thinking about having uh kids
uh got the names picked out they're
gonna be donut and the golden hen
i know what you're thinking how do you
know they're gonna be girls
but a mother knows a mother
uh i hope nobody here is deeply
religious if you are please just rest in
the glory that i am wrong
uh
but uh i was trying to believe in god
because i have heard it is supposed to
feel good uh this is what i imagine it
feels like to believe in god you know
when you're in a third world shanty town
at midnight and you're terrified but
then off in the distance you see the
glowing logo of an international
conglomerate and you just feel like
everything's gonna be okay
no someone's looking out for me
i'm trying to seek the exxon within
my mom is very devout and so i like to
connect with her leave her messages on
her voicemail from
the baby jesus
is she baby jesus listen i don't have a
couple of days so give me give you a
call maria will you stop leaving me
those messages
what let's just the ones from the baby
jesus
maybe jesus is leaving you messages
you better call him back
[Music]
honey it's creepy
it's
stop it
i
am
my mom always says honey whatever you
think about all the time that is what
you worship
oh that's the case i'd like everyone to
pop over their diet coke cans turn to
page 37 in their people magazines
in this holy scripture we read the
parable of miss kirstie alley
once on television then lost from pop
culture now welcome back into the
zeitgeist again in the worst dress shall
be the best dressed and the best dress
shall be the worst dress
of course i worship celebrities their
moods create weather
i uh
and they are vulnerable though i am
concerned about celebrity chef uh paula
deen because her recipes are like a
suicide note
yo we're gonna be making some sweet
dreams little balls of butter shortening
crisco fat back crackers
blubber
suet margarine mayonnaise
each day i went to a fresh nightmare the
pain is too great gonna roll that in
some granulated sugar powder sugar candy
candy corn gummy snakes mentos cookies
soup
nerds
don't look for me i've made a plan and i
will follow through with it gonna
drizzle in some hot fudge heavy cream
[Applause]
[Music]
we got to look out for each other
because there's a lot of pressure these
days people are always asking what are
you working on these days what's going
on for you what's on your plate these
days what's coming up you what's on the
next page for you
what are you working on
oh
oh i'm done
yeah i finished early
i'm actually living in a gravy boat
and it's filled with scrumptious gravy
thank you guys so much
marina banford everyone